[Music]
in the 1950s a group of ranchers in
Idaho were baffled when their sheep gave
birth to lambs with a singular deformity
mystified by these Cyclops sheep they
called in scientists from the US
Department of Agriculture to investigate
the researchers hypothesized that the
pregnant use had snacked on poisonous
birth defect causing plants they
collected the local flora and fed
samples to lab rats but struggled to
replicate the effect so they decided to
directly observe the sheep with one
scientist even living with the herd for
three summers after a decade of trial
and error
the scientists finally found the culprit
wild corn lilies the lilies contained an
active molecule with six connected rings
that they named cyclop Amin in reference
to the Cyclops sheep they didn't know
exactly how cyclop Amin caused the
defect but told ranchers to steer clear
it took about four decades before a team
of biologists led by Professor Philip
beachy stumbled upon the answer his lab
was studying a specific gene found in
many species from mice to humans called
the hedgehog gene it was named by two
scientists who later shared the Nobel
Prize for their work who found that
mutating this gene in fruit flies
produced pointy spikes like a hedgehog
beachy and his colleagues performed
genetic modifications to turn off the
Hedgehog genes in mice this resulted in
severe defects in the development of
their brains organs and eyes or rather I
then while perusing a textbook beachy
came across photos of the Cyclops sheep
and realized what had eluded scientists
for four decades something must have
gone awry involving the Hedgehog gene
let's take a step back genes contain
instructions that tell cells what to do
and when to do it and they communicate
their directives using proteins
the hedgehog gene itself tells cells to
release a so-called Hedgehog protein
which kicks off a complex series of
cellular signals here's how it works in
normal healthy development hedgehog
protein latches on to a protein called
patched that inhibits or holds patched
back allowing another protein called
smoothened to freely signal the cells
telling them where to go and what kind
of tissues to become
cyclope mean say in the form of a
delicious corn Lily interrupts this
pathway by binding on to smoothened that
locks smoothened up so that it's unable
to send the signals needed to mold the
brain into two hemispheres and form
fingers or separate eyes so even though
the hedgehog protein is still doing its
job of keeping the way clear for
smoothened cyclopia mean blocks
smoothened from passing along its
chemical message that settled the
science behind the one-eyed sheep but
beachy and his team caught the glimmer
of another more beneficial connection
they noted that uncontrolled activation
of the smoothened protein was associated
with a human syndrome it's known as
basal cell nevus syndrome and it
predisposes people to certain cancers
the scientists proposed putting cyclop
amines smoothened binding powers to good
use as a treatment for these cancers as
long as the patient wasn't pregnant
unfortunately researchers eventually
found that cyclop Amin causes negative
side effects and its chemical properties
make it difficult to work with but they
did discover that closely related
molecules are safe and effective and two
of these drugs were approved in 2012 and
2015 as skin cancer medicines when those
farmers first saw the Cyclops sheep they
could have chalked it up to a freak
genetic mutation and walked away instead
their decision to investigate turned a
mystery into medicine showing that
sometimes there's more than meets the
eye
ted-ed is a non-profit if you value our
work please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]